judy um just
uh to preface this it's becoming
apparent for some time
that um the things that we're doing in
laboratories or the vast majority of
laboratories nowadays
involved still involves a lot of manual
collection and manual observation
um and these things are very still very
valuable and and there's still a lot of
skills to be learned
and a lot to be learned from the animals
but
what we're actually starting to
understand now
as as we go further into the 21st
century is that what we're doing in
bavarians and how we're handling
handling laboratory animals has a fairly
profound effect
on the quality not only of the
experience of the animals when they're
in that bavarian but also the quality of
of experiments that we might run down
the line
in terms of function in terms of
cognition
and in terms of behavior essentially
anything that we're doing in the
bavarian
can cause disruption to the animals and
until very recently we didn't know
how long that actually lasted or what
that effect actually was
one thing that was actually very um
important to us was that
the kid's site assessment just in terms
of lab resources
if you have a lot of animals in the
laboratory or
even only a few animals
kids site assessment is still very very
important
both from a veterinary health point of
view and also from
the the technical point of view to make
sure that the animals are functioning
and acting as they should
a kid's side assessment due to a
resource issue only occurs once or twice
a day
the ability to monitor animals over 24
hour periods seven days a week
would be very very valuable up until
very recently this has been
this has been very challenging and
equally challenging to be able to do it
in a group house environment the way
that we handle animals today
in laboratories we're learning a lot
about that
and about how the best way to handle
them is essentially any way that we
handle animals and interact
with the animals disrupts their day
and night again can have a fairly
profound effect on studies that occur
down the line particularly those studies
when we're dealing with
function and behavior and tasks
that need to be that need to be
completed and when we're checking for
cognition so the handling of animals has
been shown to be
to to have a fairly detrimental effect
if we do it the wrong way
but even if we do it the right way
interacting with the animals is not
something that that they like
so when we look at how we monitor
animals currently in a
in a in a bavarian environment we're
only getting a snapshot in time with
that kids site assessment
we want to know more about the animals
and we want to know more about what's
happening
when we can't see them we want to know
how they interact with each other
and we want to look at the causes of
injuries and unexplained death so very
often the anecdote is that technician
comes in in the morning
and you see that there's a one less
animal in
in the cage one animal has expired we
don't really know the reason for that in
a lot of cases
um and it'd be very good to be able to
go back in time and be able to look at
that
but as i said a snapshot in time is
essentially what the cage side
assessment is so we want to be able to
monitor animals
longitudinally 24 hours a day and look
at those cases where the animals
are actually suffering or when we can
assess them
at those times when they should be
interacting socially we want to be able
to look at
what is the normal behavior of an animal
in its
home cage environment
the motivation for the system
that we have brought out
is essentially the the things that i've
just mentioned and
rodents are social animals uh isolation
is stressed
as stressful for them the interaction of
the laboratory
staff scientific staff these things are
all
stressful on the animals also again
they're primary
primary predominantly nocturnal and
we would really love to be able to see
how these animals are interacting with
each other
what kind of behaviors they show at
night when the lights are off
and we want to be able to from a quality
point of view
establish baseline behavior profile so
before the testing we want to know is
this cohort of animals acting the way
cohorts of animals of this type
should be acting so are they conforming
to that phenotype
and then during the study we want to be
able to look at
the effects of the handling on these
animals
of the tasks that we're making these
animals perform
and we want to to on we want to find a
way to understand that these animals are
actually staying normal
and then from a uh surveillance point of
view we want to be able to look at
welfare monitoring so
the indications of adverse effects is
there a possibility that these
show up sooner um if we're monitoring
the animals at night
if they're the things that when there's
no one in the room when there's no
technicians interacting with them
do we see indications of adverse events
and this is actually something that's
coming to the forefront now in
in laboratory animal sciences the
handling of animals and the surveillance
of animals
and the ability to monitor welfare
without doing those cage site
assessments
and there's been a lot now over the last
few years
published um in this area
it's a particularly fascinating area and
i think that the
quality issues where the effect of
the environment on the animals and the
effect of
of handling on animals and how that
how that impacts downstream studies
in cognition and behavior um i think
that that's very important and that's
something that we
are continuing to look into and continue
to refine ways
uh to pull data from that and and
overall it's a quality control issue
within laboratories nowadays
so there's been a lot of publications on
this and there'll be a lot more
um and at the end of it all you have the
automated cage
ethology that's that's springing to the
to the front now
and there are various uh devices out
there
various technologies that want to study
the the behaviors of mice
you want to look at as i said initially
longitudinally
but there are fewer devices that are
actually looking at
animals in their social context in their
home
cage so a lot of these are task oriented
the animal is still working
in in isolation or or living in
isolation when it's in that environment
so it's probably more more valuable
um and probably more true to the actual
phenotype to keep the stress levels of
the animal down as low as possible
and to look at them when they're group
housed
and to have it in a typical cage
so that when things like cage changes
are made
or when technicians are interacting with
them
the environment isn't overly different
if we can
if we can control that then it stands to
reason that we can have a better control
downstream when we're actually running a
lot of the task
oriented assays that we would like to
run in cognition and behavior
so in 2011 along with the
mary lyon center the mouse research
center
at harwell the mrc
at the university of edinburgh and
actual analytics in conjunction with
uh sponsorship by the nc3rs
took up the crackit challenge and the
cracker challenge
uh was created to address
uh some of the concepts that we've um
that i've alluded to
previously here so in a regular home
cage
essentially any any cage in any bavarian
that was ibc compatible
to maintain the social housing of
animals so that they wouldn't be in
isolation
with very little impact on husbandry and
to give us a 24 7
insight so a longitudinal insight into
what was occurring
in the home cage uh minute by minute
second by second day by day
month by month if it had to happen and
on top of that we looked at how
how many key behaviors would we be able
to start to analyze automatically
through a form of machine learning in
the home cage in that social environment
and from that came the actual analytics
home page analyzer
it consists of an rfid chip you can see
there it's very very small
fits into either the flank of the mouse
or a pouch in the
in the stomach or it can even go into
into the back um it doesn't affect the
mouse's
um gay or or or the mouse kinematics in
any way
there's a computer and a camera
and you can see that this the caves that
we're using could be pretty much any
any ivc cage um the setup itself
has a 360 nanometer or 860 nanometer
uh led infrared
lighting above the cage and a pc core i7
with an hd ready 720 25 frames per
second
camera so we're monitoring
uh essentially 25 frames a second
24 hours a day seven days a week and
you're looking at those behaviors
that are occurring in that home cage and
the social setting
um and it's actually quite uh quite
interesting what we get from it when we
look at what's happening in the light
phase and what's happening in the dark
phase and particularly when there are no
operators involved
um we generally show a video at this
point but we want but what you're
actually
what you can actually do here and what
you have we're actually showing is that
you have an automatic identification of
each mouse
at each position in the cage and a
catalog of behaviors that those mice
might be carrying out whether it's nest
building uh drinking from the water
spout
feeding from the hopper showing
aggression towards each other
grooming so there's a various uh a
various catalog of behaviors
the machine learns those behaviors it
creates a classifier
and then that starts to automatically be
tabulated
and at the same time you're measuring
from a base plate
so you're measuring the locomotor
activity and then there's an algorithm
that brings that together with the
camera
so that if something were to occur say
in the middle of the night
that was um unobserved
by uh by uh by an operator you would be
able to flag that
the system would be able to flag that
for you
and you would be able to go and actually
witness what happened
uh at that point in time so what we've
actually started to see is that
certain phenotypes that are known not to
be aggressive when they're housed
together
do actually get quite aggressive in in
in the dark period or they do actually
get aggressive in the light period when
there's no operators around
or the or vice versa we see nest
building
uh in some animals where there wasn't
supposed to be nest building that did
not happen when it was being observed
and essentially the most important thing
is we can actually see the social
interaction
we can see how these animals are
interacting with each other
we can see the social hierarchy within
the cage itself
and that comes out both in the automated
analysis
and in the the ability to annotate
specific pieces of video and go back and
analyze those
specific pieces of video so interpreting
the base plate data the base plate works
in concert
with the camera um
if we were just looking at locomotor
activity um
we would see something that you see in
the bottom left essentially
it looks like a whole lot of lines going
across the checkerboard but what are
what our machine is actually showing us
is what you see on the top left
if we had uh an observer from the top
down looking at it they would be
essentially
drawing something that was close to that
sort of the filled line the filled blue
line
um and the filled green line but when we
actually have the machine doing it the
machine
learns to do it quicker and quicker and
we have what you see as the
sort of the the unfilled line
so when we do the valuation we manually
annotate the position of each animal
every second
um and then the machine learns that
starts to do that and then it calculates
the distances
that the animals are moving and that
correlates the distance so that's from
the camera and then that correlates that
distance with the base plate
and as you can see from the
graph on the top right hand side as the
machine learns
this it gets better and better so that
eventually the machine begins to um
observe the animals and track the
animals um
again 24 hours seven days a week if you
needed it
in a way that is significantly better
than
a single operator and even more
significantly better than
two operators doing it
and this gives us a good idea of social
interactions between animals
and this slide that we're looking at
right now
again with a video would we would be
able to
sort of show you this um how the video
looks for this
but regardless this this statistics that
come off from this
actually can because it can identify
each animal individually
we can look at the amount of time that
they spend interacting with each other
and this point of time they spend away
from each other
along with the distance that they spend
away from each other
so that gives us one idea of the social
interactions in the in the cage
and also gives us an idea of the overall
hierarchy within the cage and this
actually becomes quite important from a
husbandry point of view
it also becomes important from an animal
welfare point of view because when we
see animals that are underweight
and we don't quite know why or we're
looking for drug effects
we're looking for re-socialization
effects in some models
or resocialization after we've extracted
an animal
and gone and either scanned it
or put it in another assay where it
might have been isolated
for some time the resocialization is
actually very important and some animals
don't resocialize right away
and other animals we socialize
immediately so we can actually see that
if if there were any detrimental effects
of subsequent assays on these animals
the next slide actually shows that um
you know
when we move animals so we have a graph
you have three graphs here
you essentially have three different
screens of animals
each line in that graph is the amount of
um activity over
a 48-hour basis you can see that the the
light cycle and the day cycle those are
cut off into 12 hour
sections you can see immediately uh
empirically that you
you have a lot more movement in the dark
cycle that's to be expected
but what actually comes out of that is
what you see under the red arrows that
some animals uh handle disturbances or
anticipate disturbances like
movement in the in the the barium cage
changes
some animals actually anticipate these
better than other animals
and some animals actually continue uh
with
more actively into the light phase than
uh was previously known so the end of
this active phase
at lights on depends on what strain
you're dealing with
so we start to see very discreet
differences between
strains and very discreet differences
between
what's happening the circle up on the
top left hand corner is essentially a
cage change
so this this shows you how the animals
are reacting after the cage change
and how long they they
they will react to that cage change so
it would also be able to give you that
quality control measure
that you could take into subsequent
assays so if your animals are not quite
settled down
if this circadian rhythm is is in some
way disrupted
um if there's been uh two
um if you've had an acclimatization
period
that hasn't been long enough once the
animals have entered the barium
then you'll actually start to see this
um
quite visibly on your computer screen uh
and it's easy to parse that out it's
easy to find individual animals that
aren't reacting the same as other
animals
and it's easy to see animals that aren't
socializing in a way that we would have
thought that they would have
so it's possible uh just from looking
that kid's side checks are not actually
showing us
everything that we see so they don't
really recapitulate that
undisturbed cage um and
we can only check those cages so often
in a day
but what you're actually seeing here is
a trace of that motion over 48 hours
and you're seeing um how active those
animals are you can see obviously that
during the light phase they're spending
there's a lot more down time
and then there's a lot more active time
and you can see exactly how active those
animals are during that phase
when we look at stereotypical behaviors
and hyperactivity
um and especially in terms of endpoints
what we're actually showing here is you
have
three separate animals there's um
the blue lines the green line and the
red line
and you can see that the red light uh
the circle sorry
the red circle animal uh almost
immediately
is showing more hyperactivity
during the dark cycle
and you know that carries on over
over a few days to the point where it's
really moving a lot
during the dark cycle and during the day
cycle you can see that it is a
slightly more hyperactive but not
something that would stick out
from the other animals in the cage
when we look at it closer and we check
the cage
we actually start to see that at the
time we checked the cage the animal
didn't look hyperactive at all
and if you look at the subsequent cage
checks on the necks on day two
at the same time that animal itself
isn't showing any different than any
other animal
in in that cage yeah at those times when
we're not checking the cage
as we move into the dark cycle that
animal is incredibly hyperactive
so whether this was drug effect or
whether this was
simply an animal that was that that was
not conforming to the phenotype of the
other animals in the cage
or whether there was something that was
uh wrong with it centrally
we had still gotten to the point where
you know at these checks at the end of
those checks
um we had hit the humane endpoint for
that animal it was moving
uh stereotypically in a way that that
just wouldn't allow us to use it in
further studies
we probably could have intervened
earlier with that
had we been able to look at what was
happening during that dark
cycle so if you look particularly again
at day one
and day two at the dark cycle you can
see that that animal is acting
uh differently than the other animals in
the cage
so the consequences of not knowing that
would be
putting that that animal into put some
functional or behavioral assays uh and
and having that have an effect on on the
end results from those assays
here's a another example of what we're
seeing
um from the from the observations so
again
if we're looking at these animals
continually throughout the dark
phase and throughout the light phase we
see that with this
um with this group of three
uh c57 um black six males
we have roughly 25 cages so all of those
numbers at the bottom are our separate
cages
and we can see that we have one
hyperactive subject
in one cage and that animal is actually
pulling the other two
with it so that phase in the light phase
if we had checked that cage we wouldn't
see anything abnormal
but during the dark phase we can see
that it is uh
an extreme outlier and not only is an
extreme outlier it's also cooling the
other two animals with
it so one hyperactive animal in a cage
that we can spot
is essentially creating uh the other
animal or creating that
that environment to be relatively
unsettled
and pulling those other animals with it
so if we and we did when we removed that
animal from that cage
uh we actually see that the
hyperactivity or the the level of
activity
in that cage along with the other
animals uh pretty much settles down
we um we're particularly interested in
being able to look at welfare deficits
um and we looked at
uh or the mrc and some of the other
partners looked at a
a group of animals
or different groups of animals that had
different phenotypes
in this case we had a good example from
a specific neurological mutant
that animal you can see is in the center
of the screen kind of
lying on top of the tube now if you look
at the top
at the distance traveled in the top left
left-hand corner
you can see the light phase and the dark
phases labeled that animal
itself is the animal that was traced in
blue
uh during the day we don't see any
differences
in the interaction um that it's spending
with the other animals so it's
interacting fine but we see at night
that the amount of time that it's not
moving
is actually significantly different than
the other animals so our
our trace in green pretty much shows the
the
the a single animal through the dark
phase
and the trace in red and blue uh are the
other animals
and the blue animal itself is the one
that you see in front of you most
clearly
and um we can identify the fact that
that animal
is actually quite sick um so simply
after a 24-hour trace we can see that
her were we to look at it in the daytime
examine it in the daytime it would be
fine
but willie to look at over 24 hours
is interacting with animals a lot less
and is also moving a lot less than the
other animals in the dark phase when it
should be moving
just as much as the other ones
we can find um social isolates so in a
particular mutant for social isolation
we can see that the interaction between
specific animals
and this is being done automatically
it's giving us this interaction between
that animal and the other animals and
the other animals in the cage and each
other
and we can see that the wild type a
and b interaction both day and night
is significantly higher but the
interaction between either of those
animals and the social isolate mutant
is significantly lower so that's
conforming to phenotype we can detect
that phenotype
uh and we can spot and in both this case
and in very many other cases we can spot
that animal that is the outlier we can
spot that animal that has a different
phenotype than the other animals so the
ability to
label animals
discreetly and to be able to
identify each animal and each behavior
discretely over time and distinctly over
time
is uh very very important and we think
that this is
actually uh essentially giving us a very
different view
of the dynamics both within the cage and
within the bavarian
and between operators and the animals
than we've ever really had before
particularly when we've been dealing
with animals that were in isolation
or when we were only checking the
animals uh in their
cages in their home cages uh once per
day
or twice per day so again this is the
kind of graphical reader that you get
we had established that um that there
was
a lot less interaction between the
mutant and the other animals
and this is what it essentially looks
like so you can see from
uh trace c that you have a lot of
interaction between
animal one on the top row of of trace c
and the second row of trace c
but virtually no interaction uh between
those two animals and the third animal
on trace c so during the dark phase
the social isolate the mutant is keeping
itself
very very far away from the other
animals again
a video shows this a lot more succinctly
so i'll just describe it for you the
animal there is label
you can see it's got its individual
label we can tell that's the social
isolate
and the other two animals are
essentially underneath the hopper
and it keeps itself at a considerable
distance from those animals
pretty much all the time
we also now have the opportunity to look
a lot deeper at novel behaviors
and also to be able to do things that we
formally
looked at in animals in isolation
so things like rearing nest building um
climbing um drinking
eating uh social transmission
preferences aggression grooming
we can have that recorded for us and we
can have that
actually telling then the machine is
actually telling us
how many times the animals will do these
on a daily basis
if one animal stops doing it um
it'll give us the social distancing
between those animals
and we can actually start to see that a
lot of the behaviors
uh that we would have normally seen in
isolation if we take the animal or
take it to a different room look at it
in isolation
those behaviors manifest themselves
significantly
differently in the home cage and what
we're actually doing with that is
creating a repository of exact terms
for what is happening how what is the
condition of these animals what
behaviors are they actually
manifesting and then we're making
informed decisions about
what assays to run are these animals
capable have we met the ethical
endpoints
for a certain animal or are the
conditions in our vivarium
suitable to for for these animals and
that can change
change from transgenic to transgenic
from mutant to mutant
um but the fact remains is that we're
we're thinking about it now
from the animals point of view what is
actually happening in the home cage what
is the social status within that cage
and how is that status affecting welfare
of the animal
and how can we intervene if we have to
um here is uh another slide that shows
actually the
philosophy behind the system as well as
mechanically how the system works
you have a blue tracing which is
uh the base plate tracing and you have
the
green tracing which is overlaid
on that that is the tracing from the
camera
and both of those go hand in hand and
what we've got here is an animal who's
um on one of the cage features
is standing up to eat from the hopper so
the base plate
is no longer measuring it but when we
looked at that
and if we spread that time out you'd see
it was a fairly significant amount of
time that it spent
um on on top of that feature
we didn't see any base plate data but
the
because the camera is recording and
because the algorithm works in concert
with the basically and the camera
we can tell that it's not no motion for
the animal the animal is actually
standing and eating
so we go back to that point in time and
we look at that particular piece of
video
and we see the explanation for why we
suddenly got no
no locomotor activity data from the base
plate
um and i think that's actually a
particularly valuable
feature of the system is the fact that
you're not simply
recording with a base plate and you're
not simply recording with the video
you actually have both of them working
together in concert
an algorithm that pulls them together so
that you're getting
a complete view um
a three-dimensional view of animal
animal behavior in that social setting
in that
in that home cage setting
uh so as i had mentioned previously the
specifications are that it's a full hd
video
uh you're about 25 frames per second
what you see
over the top is an infrared lighting
panel
uh each setup has its own
pc core i7
computer um and then what we actually do
is we capture a small number of examples
we build classifiers on those examples
those classifiers go on to capture a lot
of examples and it's a sort of a
self-training loop
from that and then we test that
classifier on the remainder of the
examples and we get these
distinct behaviors these distinct
in-cage behaviors
in the social setting there are certain
challenges
is to keep to designing these
classifiers faster
and to get enough quality annotations
for it so
specific behaviors that may be unique
to a particular phenotype we need to
identify those we can do that
when we get that video and then we start
to rebuild the classifiers from that
and then hopefully and in most cases it
works
fairly seamlessly we can start to
identify individual animals
distinct behaviors and and look at
those animals discreetly with respect to
the other animals in the cage itself
and we get a menu that would look
something similar to this
it's a behavioral annotation you can see
from the two panels
the two pictures at the top of the slide
each animal is ident
identified individually um
this is an overlay obviously an operator
wouldn't
need to see this they wouldn't need to
know which animal was which
but on its own we can actually start to
look at
you know after a period of annotation we
can actually see the periods of
aggression
we can see which two animals were
aggressive towards each other can we see
when they're drinking we can see when
they're feeding we can see when they're
grooming uh we can see general
locomotion so you can see if one animal
is moving a lot more than the others
um we can see the rearing and we can
also see the social grooming so when
they when they groom each other
the approach actually just involves uh
using local trainer
patterns so what we would actually do is
as
is is programming the features in the
cage
rather simply so that we have uh
we know where the water spout is we know
where the feeding hopper is and we know
where some of the features in the cage
are these can move around somewhat
and then we can spot the animals and
then when we know
uh distinctly what the animal is doing
locomotive behavior
we can actually start to see is it
actually drinking or is it just spending
time around the water spout
um is it actually borrowing for
something
or is it actually is it actually nest
building going on
um is it actually sleeping or has it
actually
expired uh these are these are the
things that we can start to look at and
look at very very closely with with
this system so our approach to this
would be essentially
using those trainer patterns
understanding the features in the cage
being able to recognize those um and
then
understanding that near the water spout
is is a region of interest
and attracts the animal to the water
spout and then how the animal drinks
when the animal is drinking
and what animal in the cage is drinking
that all helps us to build the
classifiers for this
and then that is supported through a
certain amount of machine learning
so that after an initial round of
annotations
we can start to have the machine um
record and tabulate these behaviors
automatically
so here we have an example where we have
a mutant
um in a cage with um with other animals
the mutant is in blue um and the other
animals are the control animals
and you see that during the light phase
the mutant itself is not actually
um it wouldn't actually be discernibly
drinking
a whole lot more uh from the water spout
than the other animals but you can see
that in the dark phase it is
uh drinking uh um considerably
more and more frequently than the other
animals in the cage
and than it was in the light phase so
being able to look at those statistics
and be able to look at those in
comparison with the other animals in the
cage
and be able to look at those statistics
and those animals
within the dark and in the light phase
longitudinally
is actually uh very very important and
it gives us a different insight
so in this case this was a particular
metabolic mutant
it was conforming according to phenotype
but our ability to see that and our
ability
to quantify that was something that was
a challenge before but now
we can actually quantify the amount of
time it is actually spent
um actually drinking
again we would have had a a video here
but you can see the behavioral
overlays so each animal is identified
independently or identified individually
we can see the interactions between
those animals when we do the analysis
then uh it'll show us what each
individual animal is doing and the way
that you see here
so that we can actually start to look at
um
you know specific events that occur
inside the cage
and um specific behaviors from each
animal
so again home cage social setting uh
things are much much different when you
look at animals this way
um than previously uh either looking at
them in isolation
or just sort of doing the cage side
check or looking at them
uh and in specific functional assays
so in summary uh the crackit challenge
uh met by actual analytics the mrc
and the uh sponsored by the nc3rs at the
time
uh you know it brought the analysis into
the cage itself
and it allowed us to score a range of
behavior behaviors automatically
and now we actually see that there are
clear effects
of group housing versus isolated housing
and clear effects of handling and
clear effects of what is actually
happening in the bavarian
and the environment outside of the cage
and again as i had said it gives us a
very different
um insight
as to how we've been dealing with with
animals in the laboratory setting
uh you know previous to know
um here was a particular example from
mrc that actually showed um
neurodegeneration and you see that the
distance traveled
uh eight weeks fairly similar between
the two animals
but then we actually see that the
neurodegenerative animal
starts to was doing a lot of climbing
when we didn't actually expect it so
during the daytime we didn't actually
see that climbing
but after we had the ability to look at
it when there was no one around we
actually
saw that that climbing behavior was
actually increased in the um
in the in the hd animal and then
sort of started to normalize uh over to
over time
but it was quite surprising to see it
that in the dark phase that this animal
was actually climbing when we didn't
expect it to
um you can actually start to
identify individual outliers so you see
our way
our wild type control cohort is the
thick blue line and then the
red and the green are actually
individual animals
and we can see how close those
individual animals are
acting towards how close those
individual animals are
acting towards the well-type controls
so the red animal itself is actually
fairly
uh in terms of it its pattern is is
acting much differently than
the control animals and also the
the animal in green so these individual
animals are
somewhat conforming to phenotype during
the day but
in the evenings uh the red animal in
particular
is an outlier it was actually very very
sick
it wouldn't have been noticed or it
would have been hard to notice it during
the daytime
but in the night time when we analyze
the data we can see that it's not
conforming to phenotype at all
and it's not even close to what the
well-type controls are so that actually
gives us an indication of the welfare of
that animal
uh it was an outlier and would have it
had we
examined it much closer would have been
close to the ethical end point
and then looking at the current system
that we have with the live telemetry
and analysis looking back uh at the the
previous slide
this animal in red our uh ethical
endpoints
were essentially set um
you can see that in the graph on the on
the right and then this animal hit the
ethical endpoint
and carried on beyond it so we
identified that outlier
with the system uh but not
through observation um and
we more than likely would have been able
to identify it
uh significantly earlier uh
had we been looking uh at the system
data
it was only later on afterwards when we
actually started to
compare the two the the observational
data
uh from the kids kids side check and the
data that was being generated by the
system that we saw that this was indeed
an outlier
now had that animal gone on or even both
of those animals gone on to
to subsequent uh behavioral
cognitive or functional assays then we
might have had
a had a problem there would have been a
possibility that the results may have
been skewed one way or the other
and then when we look at this uh
continuing to look at this
neurodegenerative phenotype as an
example
the ethogram that shows the locomotor
activity and the climbing activity
um over a two-hour period either side of
light so i'm sure from 6 a.m to
8 a.m you can see the locomotion and
climbing
uh in both the well type and the
hd animal were actually very very high
uh when the lights were off
um a little bit more as you would expect
uh in the weld types uh during the
daytime but in the
evening the the locomotive activity for
the uh
neurodegenerative animal the hd animal
acts was actually
considerably high um and that's not
witnessed at all during the daytime
so almost uh no climbing at all during
when the lights are on
but when the lights are off quite a lot
of climbing
um and also the amount of movement
during the daytime would have been
about what we expected but in the
evening
as the lights are off you you actually
are almost entering a hyperactive phase
so looking at uh interaction of animals
is
obviously very important something that
we can do so here's
individual animals that um
that we were looking at and we look at
the range of behaviors
uh in those animals during the light and
the dark phase
uh you can start to spot the outliers
you can start to spot those animals
that that were lesions you can see that
the tbi
animal is in the uh and
the light phase is in red
and the in the dark phase it's in brown
or dark red or crimson at the top
so you can see how the animals reacting
um in different phases at different
times
and you can overlay those that data on
top of each other so that you'll be able
to start to look at
the actual behaviors of these animals
over a longitudinal period so this was
over 12 weeks
uh in three models of of trauma
and the amount of social interaction
that those animals are actually doing
uh during the day during the dark and
the light phase is significantly
different
depending on what model that you
actually had
so uh in light of the fact that i didn't
have the videos
uh to show i think that does actually
give a good
overview of the system and
um i'm hoping that uh
if there are any questions that i can
answer
i'll i'll take them from you but i
really appreciate your time
and i think i'll end it there thanks
very much and also thank you to our
collaborators with
you know obviously actual analytics and
that nissan science
also the mrc had headed up by sarah
wells
our initial partners astrozenica who
helped us develop the system
and the university of edinburgh queen
mary and the university of strathclyde
all right thank you very much